OK-- this happens to be Chicago, but every city has a place like this. That weird, desolate area at the far end of town. We're a half mile west of the old abandoned steel mills. We're a half mile north of landfills where methane fires used to burn. Just south of the auto junkyard.
好吧——这里恰好是芝加哥，但每个城市都有这样一个地方。在城郊远端那片诡异而荒凉的地带。我们在废弃旧钢铁厂以西半英里处，在过去曾燃烧甲烷火焰的垃圾填埋场以北半英里处，就在汽车回收站的正南边。
Just east of the site of the old city dump, where there was a mountain of raw garbage that would stink up the neighborhood whenever the wind would blow in the wrong direction. Everybody down here called it Mount Pacini, for the alderman who let the city put it here.
在旧城市垃圾场遗址的正东边，那里曾有一座堆积如山的原始垃圾，每当风向不对时，就会把整个街区熏得恶臭不堪。这里的每个人都管它叫“帕西尼山”（Mount Pacini），这是以那位允许市政府在此倾倒垃圾的参议员的名字命名的。
You will notice all these-- what would you call it-- tire marks. This street is used for drag racing year-round.
你会注意到所有这些——你管它们叫什么——轮胎痕迹。这条街常年被用来进行非法飙车。
Really?
真的吗？
Yeah, because it's basically far enough away from the police that they don't do anything about it.
是的，因为这里离警察足够远，他们根本不会管。
My guide is Charlie Gregerson, who grew up down here. He shows me where a lake, Lake Calumet, used to be back in the '40s when he was a kid. He'd go fishing on a rowboat with his dad.
我的向导是查理·格雷格森，他就在这附近长大。他向我展示了40年代他小时候卡柳梅特湖（Lake Calumet）曾经所在的位置。那时他常和父亲划着小木船去钓鱼。
Then the city started filling in huge sections of the lake with garbage and incinerator ash. He'd come here in the '70s and see bulldozers pushing around the rubble of some of Chicago's great buildings which had been recently demolished. Louis Sullivan masterpieces like the Stock Exchange Building and the Garrick Theater-- this is where they ended up.
后来，城市开始用垃圾和焚烧炉灰烬填埋湖泊的巨大区域。他在70年代来到这里时，看到推土机正在推平芝加哥一些伟大建筑的瓦砾，这些建筑不久前刚被拆毁。像路易斯·沙利文（Louis Sullivan）的杰作——证券交易所大楼（Stock Exchange Building）和加里克剧院（Garrick Theater）——最终都落到了这里。
Now show me-- we're standing here-- where were all the buildings being dumped? And what did that look like?
现在告诉我——我们就站在这儿——所有那些建筑都是在哪里被倾倒的？看起来是什么样子？
Right here at what was the north end of the dump. I actually picked up a few pieces of the Stock Exchange ornament right out of the lake. But, of course, most of it had been ground right into the dirt, because they had bulldozers that would just dump the stuff in piles, and the bulldozer would just flatten them all out.
就在这里，在垃圾场的北端。我甚至直接从湖里捡到了一些证券交易所大楼的装饰件。但当然，大部分都被碾碎在泥土里了，因为推土机只是把这些东西成堆地倒下，然后直接推平。
And so there would be this Louis Sullivan terra cotta ornament just sticking out?
所以路易斯·沙利文的陶土装饰就那样露在外面？
Just laying out there, yeah.
就那样散落在外面，是的。
And so walking around when there's these pieces of buildings sticking up. It just seems like it must have been such a strange scene. Like this apocalyptic death of a city.
走在那些建筑碎片耸立的地方，感觉一定很奇怪。就像一个城市末日般的死亡景象。
Oh, yeah. I remember seeing one of these big phoenix columns-- that I knew had come out of the Garrick Theater-- was just sticking out of the ground. Two of those in the Garrick Theater distributed the weight of the upper floors that were over the stage. One of those was just sticking out at about a 45 degree angle out of the ground. And at that point, the Garrick had been gone for almost 10 years.
噢，是的。我记得看到过其中一根巨大的凤凰柱——我知道它是从加里克剧院拆下来的——就那样矗立在地面上。加里克剧院里有两根这样的柱子，用于支撑舞台上方楼层的重量。其中一根就那样以45度角从地里探出来。当时，加里克剧院已经消失近10年了。
There were once big plans for this area-- for canals and waterways, a harbor that never really worked out. There are zoning maps of the city that show streets and complete neighborhoods, a whole grid of them, that nobody ever got around to building. Instead, now, on top of all the trash, stands a golf course.
这个地区曾经有过宏伟的规划——运河、水道，还有一个从未真正建成的港口。城市的分区地图上显示着街道和完整的社区，一整套网格规划，但从未有人真正去建设。相反，现在在所有这些垃圾之上，伫立着一个高尔夫球场。
Charlie says that from the clubhouse he gets exactly the same view that he used to get back when he and his dad took out the rowboat. It's the same spot. That's where the lake once was. You can see clear to downtown. So far away, it might as well be another city.
查理说，从会所望出去的景色，和他当年与父亲划船时看到的完全一样。那是同一个地方。曾经的湖泊就在那里。你可以一眼望到市中心。它是如此遥远，仿佛是另一个城市。
Well, today on our program we have stories from several places like this. In the shadow the city, that weird no-man's land where it always feels like secret stuff is happening just out of sight. From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life, distributed by Public Radio International. I'm Ira Glass.
今天在我们的节目中，我们将讲述几个像这样的地方的故事。在城市的阴影中，那片总觉得有秘密在视野之外发生的诡异无人区。这里是来自芝加哥WBEZ的《美国生活》（This American Life），由国际公共广播电台（PRI）发行。我是艾拉·格拉斯（Ira Glass）。
Our program today in three acts. Act One, Brooklyn Archipelago. In that act, some passengers set sail one day on a three hour tour, a three hour tour, and end up getting lost in the wilderness. One fears for his life on a string of islands that is just outside a very, very big city.
我们今天的节目分三幕。第一幕，布鲁克林群岛。在这一幕中，几位乘客某天乘船开始了一次三小时的旅行，结果却迷失在荒野中。有人在一连串位于一座非常非常大的城市边缘的岛屿上，为自己的生命感到恐惧。
Act Two, The Thin Gray Line. In that act, a tour bus takes out-of-towners into areas where tourists never tread. To see destruction, tragedy,
第二幕，灰色细线。在这一幕中，一辆旅游巴士将外地游客带到了游客从未踏足的地方。去见证毁灭与悲剧。
Act Three. Please, In My Backyard. A controversy over industrial odors coming from a factory. Odors that people actually want to keep. Stay with us.
第三幕，拜托，别在我家后院。关于一家工厂产生的工业异味的争议。那是人们实际上想要保留的气味。请继续收听。
Act One, Brooklyn Archipelago. Brett Martin has this story, which takes place on the outskirts of, well, perhaps you've already figured out which city.
第一幕，布鲁克林群岛。布雷特·马丁（Brett Martin）带来了这个故事，它发生在一个……好吧，也许你已经猜到是哪个城市的郊区。
Listen, it happens. You go out for a night with your friends, and you wind up drunk, in your underwear, soaking wet, covered with blood, and shipwrecked on a desert island, all within sight of the Empire State Building. These things happen. Or at least, they did happen to Alex Zharov.
听着，这种事时有发生。你和朋友出去玩了一晚，结果喝得烂醉，只穿着内衣，浑身湿透，满身是血，还荒岛遇难，而这一切就在帝国大厦的视野范围内。这些事情就是会发生。或者至少，它们发生在亚历克斯·扎罗夫（Alex Zharov）身上。
Alex is 17-years-old. He moved to the US from a small town in the Ukraine when he was nine. He's skinny and wears tie dyed t-shirts, an unmanageable spray of frizzy blonde hair, and a valiant, if not altogether successful, starter mustache. And, well, he can probably introduce himself better than I can. Here's how he responds when I ask him to state his name for the record.
亚历克斯17岁。他九岁时从乌克兰的一个小镇搬到美国。他很瘦，穿着扎染T恤，留着一头乱蓬蓬、难以打理的金发，还留着一撮勇敢但不太成功的“新手胡子”。而且，嗯，他可能比我更会自我介绍。当我问他记录一下自己的名字时，他是这样回答的。
My name is Alex Zharov, and I love to have very radical experiences in life. And I consider myself to be a psychedelic artistically productive person.
我的名字是亚历克斯·扎罗夫，我喜欢在生活中体验非常激进的经历。我自认为是一个在艺术上富有成效的迷幻主义者。
Here are a few other things about Alex. He lives with his cute, older girlfriend and his exceptionally patient parents in a small apartment in the Midwood section of Brooklyn. Instead of going to high school, he's enrolled in an internet home schooling program. He's at work on a science fiction novel and has logged several hundred in-flight hours as a student pilot.
关于亚历克斯还有几件事。他和可爱的年长女友以及极其宽容的父母住在布鲁克林米德伍德（Midwood）区的一间小公寓里。他没有上高中，而是报名参加了互联网家庭学校课程。他正在写一部科幻小说，并以学生飞行员的身份记录了几百小时的飞行时间。
But most of Alex's time is spent as the guitarist, singer, and songwriter for his band, Ebuffalo. When I went to see them play at a two-day Russian rock festival last fall, I learned several things. First, there are many, many ex-Soviet immigrants living in Brooklyn. Second, they all very earnestly want to rock. And third, Alex Zharov, whether he's writhing on his back on stage or reclining in the dressing room with a beer and a cigarette, he's kind of a superstar.
但亚历克斯大部分时间是作为他的乐队Ebuffalo的吉他手、歌手和词曲作者。去年秋天，当我去看他们参加一个为期两天的俄罗斯摇滚音乐节时，我了解到了几件事。首先，有许许多多的前苏联移民住在布鲁克林。其次，他们都非常认真地想要摇滚。第三，亚历克斯·扎罗夫，无论是在舞台上扭动身体，还是在后台一边喝啤酒一边抽烟，他都是某种超级明星。
Before we get to our story, the other key person you'll need to meet is someone who entered Alex's life at a crucial moment years ago, when Alex first came to the States. Alex had an awkward adjustment. He fought in school and was kind of depressed. He was bored.
在我们进入故事之前，你需要认识的另一个关键人物，是多年前亚历克斯刚来美国、处于人生关键时刻时走进他生活的人。亚历克斯曾有过一段尴尬的适应期。他在学校打架，有点抑郁。他感到无聊。
Then one day, Alex was walking along the Brighton Beach Boardwalk and saw a group of older guys collecting money for something called the Russian Punk Rock Club of America. Older guys like 25 and 30-years-old-- Alex was 12. One of the musicians he met that day was Roman Gadzhilov, who immediately took to the young Alex.
有一天，亚历克斯走在布莱顿海滩（Brighton Beach）的木板路上，看到一群大一点的人在为一个叫“美国俄罗斯朋克摇滚俱乐部”的组织募捐。那些大一点的人大约25、30岁——亚历克斯当时12岁。那天他见到的其中一位音乐人叫罗曼·加吉洛夫（Roman Gadzhilov），他立刻就喜欢上了年轻的亚历克斯。
Well, he had this blink in his eyes. And sometimes you see extraordinary person, and you kind of know this. He wasn't appear to us as 12-year-old at that moment. At 12-years-old, he was writing songs that I was writing at 18. And after this, we've been together all the time.
嗯，他的眼睛里闪烁着光芒。有时你看到一个非凡的人，你会有一种感觉。那一刻，他给我们的感觉不像个12岁的孩子。12岁时，他写的歌我18岁才写出来。从此以后，我们一直在一起。
We call him [? Krusha. ?]
我们叫他“小猪”（Krusha）。
And what does that mean?
那是什么意思？
[? Krusha ?] means "little piglet."
“小猪”的意思就是“小猪崽”。
Under his new friends' tutelage, Alex began walking around in an old Bolshevik style hat and trench coat. And his friends gave him books-- Dostoevsky, Tolkien, guides to Slavic paganism, the Beats, and also Robinson Crusoe & Treasure Island. Alex was particularly fond of those.
在新朋友的教导下，亚历克斯开始戴着一顶旧布尔什维克风格的帽子，穿着风衣到处走。他的朋友给了他书籍——陀思妥耶夫斯基、托尔金、斯拉夫异教指南、垮掉派的作品，还有《鲁滨逊漂流记》和《金银岛》。亚历克斯特别喜欢这些。
And our story today, our own seafaring tale, happens on a boat that Roman owns. A 25-foot white sailboat which Alex likes to refer to as "the yacht." One cool evening last May, Alex, Roman and another friend named Alex, Alex Glubochansky, decided to take a nice little boat trip in Jamaica Bay, the body of water that wraps around the southern end of Brooklyn. Here's Alex.
而我们今天的故事，我们自己的航海故事，发生在一艘罗曼拥有的船上。一艘25英尺长的白色帆船，亚历克斯喜欢称之为“游艇”。去年五月的一个凉爽夜晚，亚历克斯、罗曼和另一个叫亚历克斯的朋友——亚历克斯·格卢博钱斯基（Alex Glubochansky），决定去牙买加湾（Jamaica Bay）进行一次愉快的短途航行，那片水域环绕着布鲁克林的南端。这是亚历克斯的叙述。
The three of us decided to just get 10 gallons of gas. And my friend Roman, he got a bottle of rum. And we got two cans of food, and we just decided to have a cool trip on the yacht. And I started saying, oh, our goal is the open ocean. Let's sail to Poland, I told them.
我们三个人决定加10加仑汽油。我的朋友罗曼带了一瓶朗姆酒。我们带了两罐食物，决定开着游艇去兜风。我开始说，噢，我们的目标是公海。我告诉他们，咱们去波兰吧。
Roman had a slightly less ambitious agenda.
罗曼的计划没有那么宏大。
The plan was just to go under the Rockaway Bridge, then turn around and then come back. It should have taken about 40 minutes.
计划只是从洛克威大桥（Rockaway Bridge）下面穿过，然后掉头回来。这大约只需要40分钟。
Things started to go wrong almost immediately. Before they even left the marina, Roman, who'd been making headway through the bottle of rum, fell into the water, and they had to haul him back in. He was clearly in no shape to drive. This is Alex.
事情几乎立刻就开始出错了。甚至在他们离开码头之前，一直都在对付那瓶朗姆酒的罗曼就掉进了水里，他们不得不把他拉回来。他显然已经没有能力掌舵了。这是亚历克斯的说法。
He got drunk, and he just was babbling something, laughing. Like he said, don't go there, don't go there. And he was constantly saying, don't hit the shallows. He already didn't control the situation by that time.
他喝醉了，只会嘟囔些什么，大笑。他一直说，别去那儿，别去那儿。他不停地重复，不要触礁。那时候他已经完全失控了。
As a responsible journalist, I should say for the record that Roman does have one objection to Alex's version of events.
作为一名负责任的记者，我必须说明，罗曼对亚历克斯的故事版本有一个异议。
It wasn't rum, by the way, it was cognac. I don't know why everybody puts rum. So it was a cognac.
顺便说一句，那不是朗姆酒，是干邑白兰地。我不知道为什么每个人都说是朗姆酒。那是干邑白兰地。
You're sure?
你确定？
It was a Lautrec. Yes, it was Lautrec cognac. I don't know how come it's become rum. Alex told it was rum, but it was cognac. Not a little bit, it was a lot. I was out of commission.
是劳特雷克（Lautrec）干邑。是的，那是劳特雷克干邑。我不知道为什么传成了朗姆酒。亚历克斯说是朗姆酒，但那是干邑。而且不是一点点，是很多。我当时已经完全丧失行动能力了。
Alex and Alex had had a few drinks themselves.
亚历克斯和亚历克斯自己也喝了几杯。
But we were perfectly sober and everything. We might have had a few drinks, but we were perfectly sober.
但我们完全清醒，一切正常。我们可能喝了几杯，但我们绝对清醒。
But neither of you knows how to drive a boat?
但你们俩谁都不会开船？
No. But we got a hold of it. It wasn't that hard. So we knew how to drive it, so it didn't seem pretty hard. You turn on the motor. You turn the boat. It turns, cool.
不会。但我们摸索了一下。并不难。我们学会了怎么开，所以看起来没那么难。打开引擎，转动船舵。它就转了，酷。
Somehow they managed to get out of the marina, gun the engine, and take off across the water toward the Marine Park Bridge in the distance. Once there, they decided to try to sail to Brighton Beach and headed toward a land mass. But they got confused and turned back to open water.
他们以某种方式设法离开了码头，猛踩油门，向远处的海军公园大桥（Marine Park Bridge）疾驰而去。到达那里后，他们决定尝试航行到布莱顿海滩，并朝着一片陆地驶去。但他们迷失了方向，又回到了开阔的水域。
They drank some rum, or maybe cognac. One way or another, they drank a lot of it. At one point, they almost crashed into a small island. Gas was running low, but they figured that if worse came to worse, they could always put up the sails and still make it home.
他们喝了一些朗姆酒，或者可能是干邑白兰地。不管怎样，他们喝了很多。有一次，他们差点撞上一座小岛。汽油快用完了，但他们想，如果情况变得更糟，他们总能升起帆，依然可以回家。
Then they got caught in a strong current that turned the boat in circles. The perfect time, you would think, to begin to panic. Or, if you're the kind of person who forgets trouble the moment you're out of it, or even while you're in it, the perfect time to shoot off all the boat's flares-- into the water, just for fun.
然后他们被一股强劲的海流困住，导致船只不停地打转。你会认为这是开始恐慌的绝佳时机。或者，如果你是那种一旦脱离麻烦就忘记麻烦的人，甚至在麻烦中也一样，这是把船上所有的信号弹全部发射出去的绝佳时机——只是为了好玩。
Finally, the series of mistakes reached a critical mass. They had no cell phone-- Roman's had died when he fell in the water-- no flares, no captain, and almost no gas. Even Alex had to admit they were in trouble.
最终，一系列的错误达到临界点。他们没有手机——罗曼的手机在掉进水里时就坏了——没有信号弹，没有船长，汽油也几乎耗尽。甚至亚历克斯也不得不承认他们遇到麻烦了。
We didn't know where we were. And then we realized that we weren't going to make it anywhere. And we were like, in the morning we'll figure out what to do. So we went to sleep.
我们不知道我们在哪儿。然后我们意识到我们哪儿也去不了。我们当时想，早上再想办法吧。于是我们就睡觉了。
It was a glorious spring morning on Jamaica Bay. Sun glinting off the water, gulls calling overhead as our young pleasure cruisers slumbered. The light filtering into the boat's cabin woke Roman and Alex Glubochansky first, and they came up on deck. What they saw was not good.
牙买加湾迎来了一个灿烂的春日早晨。阳光在水面上闪烁，海鸥在头顶鸣叫，而我们年轻的游船乘客还在熟睡。阳光照进船舱，唤醒了罗曼和亚历克斯·格卢博钱斯基，他们来到甲板上。他们看到的情况不妙。
After drifting through the night, the boat had come to rest in the shallows of a small bay alongside an uninhabited land mass. Stretching out behind them, they could see a long furrow where the tide had dragged them deep into thick mud. And as they stood there, blinking and wondering how this might have happened, the wind carried them another 10 feet inland.
在经历了一夜的漂流后，船只搁浅在一座无人岛旁的小海湾浅滩上。在他们身后，可以看到一条长长的沟壑，那是潮汐将他们拖进厚厚泥浆中留下的痕迹。正当他们站在那里，眨着眼睛纳闷这一切是怎么发生的时候，风又将他们向内陆吹了10英尺。
They could see the skyline of Manhattan on the horizon, the runways of JFK Airport a little closer, and signs of civilization in every direction. They could even see boats passing by in the distance, but these were too far away to take any notice. It was obvious that they were, in a word, shipwrecked.
他们可以看到地平线上的曼哈顿天际线，更近一点的肯尼迪机场跑道，以及四面八方的文明迹象。他们甚至可以看到远处的船只经过，但那些船太远了，根本注意不到他们。显而易见，用一个词形容：他们遇难了。
The hungover sailors sat down to decide what to do. Roman and Glubochansky were in favor of waiting to be rescued or for the tide to rise and pull them out again. Meanwhile, Alex was formulating his own plan.
这些宿醉的水手坐下来决定做什么。罗曼和格卢博钱斯基倾向于等待救援，或者等潮水上涨将船浮起。与此同时，亚历克斯正在制定自己的计划。
Beyond the island they were closest to lay another land mass which Alex was sure led somewhere. His idea was to swim to it, walk to civilization, catch a bus somewhere, and bring back help for his friends, who, as Alex remembers it, thought the plan was, frankly, idiotic. These are islands, said Roman, who in truth had actually been out on the Bay before and was in a position to know.
在他们所在的岛屿对面还有另一片陆地，亚历克斯坚信那里能通向某处。他的主意是游过去，走到文明世界，坐公交车，然后带人回来救他的朋友们。据亚历克斯回忆，他的朋友们觉得这个计划简直是白痴行为。“那是个岛，”罗曼说，事实上，他以前去过海湾，有资格说这话。
But Alex was sure that Roman was wrong. So Alex stripped to his underwear. He put what he thought he might need in a waterproof plastic mayonnaise jar. He brought his Metro card for the bus he was going to swim to, an expired passport for ID, and his favorite Buddhist medallion for luck. He wrapped his clothes in a cellophane blanket and bid his friends farewell. Roman watched him disappear into the surf.
但亚历克斯确信罗曼错了。于是亚历克斯脱得只剩内衣。他把认为需要的东西装进了一个防水的蛋黄酱塑料瓶里。他带了坐公交车的地铁卡、过期的护照作为身份证明，还有他最喜欢的佛教奖章作为好运。他把衣服包在塑料薄膜里，和朋友们告别。罗曼看着他消失在海浪中。
Of course. I tried to stop him. I tried to give him reasonable things, but he get a little bit too much excited. So I decided to give him a challenge in life. What? Should I just knock him down and say stop it? He wanted to swim, and he swam.
当然。我试图阻止他。我试着给他一些合理的建议，但他太兴奋了。所以我决定给他一个人生挑战。什么？难道我要揍他一顿说别去了吗？他想游，他就游了。
I swam really violently to get myself warmed up. And by the middle, I got really tired, and I was really cold. And I'm like, oh, this is much worse than I thought. And there's birds flying, like peeking on me. I'm like, these crazy strange [INAUDIBLE] birds are going to bite me or something.
我游得非常用力，想让自己暖和起来。游到一半时，我感到非常疲惫，而且浑身冰凉。我心想，这比我想象的糟糕多了。还有鸟在飞，像是要啄我。我想，这些疯狂古怪的鸟是想咬我吗？
And I got really lucky, because my legs suddenly hit the bottom. And I was so happy when I came out of there. I was so cold, but I was happy.
我真的很幸运，因为我的脚突然碰到了底部。当我从水里爬出来时，我太开心了。我虽然很冷，但我很高兴。
And I was definitely sure there was civilization, because tall buildings were right behind the trees. And the bridge was right over there. And I'm like, oh, finally. And I was even singing a song walking, and the birds were screaming something to me. And I'm like, yeah, I made it.
我绝对肯定那里有文明，因为树木后面就是高楼。桥就在那儿。我心想，哦，终于到了。我甚至一边走一边唱歌，鸟儿对我尖叫着什么。我想，耶，我成功了。
I'm still not sure I understand why you left your friends though.
但我还是不明白你为什么丢下你的朋友。
Because I thought we were going to be stuck there for a really long time, maybe for the whole day. The only thing I could do is just try to get to civilization. And especially these islands-- they were pressuring me to go there. They were so close.
因为我觉得我们要在那儿困很久，可能是一整天。我唯一能做的就是尝试去到文明世界。特别是这些岛屿——它们在逼着我去。它们离得太近了。
And I got really bored. You know, I wake up in the morning, I don't want to stay in one spot on the yacht and think about how we're going to get saved. I really want to do something. And I'm like, OK, I'm going to have this little adventure. I'm going to go out and try to make it somewhere, and I did.
而且我真的很无聊。你知道，我早上醒来，不想一直待在游艇上思考怎么获救。我真的很想做点什么。我心想，好吧，我要进行这次小小的冒险。我要去试着到达某个地方，我做到了。
Except he didn't. Soon he realized that he was, indeed, on another island, with no way off except to swim back through the freezing water to rejoin his friends. And he wasn't about to do that. He was alone.
其实他没做到。很快他意识到，自己确实是在另一个岛上，除了游回寒冷的水里去寻找朋友外，根本没有出路。而他并不打算那样做。他孤身一人。
So Alex set about doing all the things a good castaway should do. He wrote a giant "help" in the sand for the benefit of the planes landing at JFK. He circumnavigated the island looking for supplies. He found a stick and a piece of red cloth, and made a flag to signal passing ships. Then he found several big pieces of Styrofoam and some wood and spent an hour or two fashioning a raft, but it collapsed when he sat down on it.
于是亚历克斯开始做所有落难者该做的事。他在沙滩上写了一个巨大的“HELP”，方便肯尼迪机场降落的飞机看到。他环绕岛屿寻找补给。他找了一根棍子和一块红布，做了一面旗帜来向路过的船只求救。然后他找到了几大块聚苯乙烯泡沫塑料和一些木头，花了一两个小时拼凑成一个木筏，但他一坐上去就散架了。
Undeterred, he went back to searching for something that would be his ticket off the island. And then he found it. It was the hollowed out carcass of a jet ski, or, as he calls it, a scooter.
他不死心，又去寻找能带他离开岛屿的东西。然后他找到了。那是一具喷气式滑雪橇的残骸，或者他称之为“小摩托”。
I 100% knew that it was going to float, although it was pretty badly dug into the sand. And as I was digging out the scooter, something really bad happened. There was pieces of glass under it.
我百分之百肯定它能浮起来，尽管它深深地陷在沙子里。当我挖掘小摩托时，发生了很糟糕的事情。下面有碎玻璃。
I didn't see. I was just digging and digging, and I didn't have any shovel or anything. And I cut my finger really bad. I started getting huge amounts of blood was coming out. And I had this white t-shirt that was eventually all in blood.
我没看见。我只是不停地挖，没有任何铲子之类的工具。我的手指被割得很深。大量的血涌出来。我那件白色T恤最终全被染红了。
Now there was really no way off the island, even by swimming. Because-- well, you know-- sharks. It was a galling situation, and it was made even more maddening because the city was right there.
现在真的没有离开岛屿的方法了，即使是游泳也不行。因为——嗯，你知道——鲨鱼。这是一种令人懊恼的情况，更令人抓狂的是，城市近在咫尺。
I was thinking, how in the hell did I get myself into this situation? I never believed that something like this could happen in New York City, you know? It's such a huge city that you could see skyscrapers like 10 miles away, and on the other side you can die looking at them.
我在想，我到底是怎么把自己搞进这种境地的？我从没想过这种事会在纽约市发生，你知道吗？它是一座如此巨大的城市，你可以在10英里外看到摩天大楼，而在另一边，你却可能死在那里，眼睁睁地看着它们。
And also, I got a little mad at the city of New York. Like, I could understand if they had just one payphone there. Or at least, I don't know, a button to press to know that you're there.
而且，我对纽约市也感到有点生气。比如，我能理解如果那里有一个公用电话。或者至少，我不知道，有一个按钮可以按，让人知道你在那儿。
By probably 6 o'clock in the evening it was getting a little dark. All my excitement has fled away, and I got very cold. I was shaking, shivering, and no help at all. So I'm like, wow, this is going to get really bad.
大概到傍晚6点，天色有点暗了。我所有的兴奋都消失了，我变得非常冷。我浑身发抖，没有任何救援。我想，哇，这情况要变得非常糟糕了。
Were you hungry at this point also?
那时候你也饿了吗？
I was very hungry, and I was very thirsty. And I found limes. I tried to open them up, but they tasted so nasty. I didn't even think about eating them. There was no source of food other than the ducks.
我非常饿，也非常渴。我找到了青柠。我试着打开它们，但味道太难吃了。我甚至没想过吃它们。除了鸭子，没有任何食物来源。
Ah yes, the ducks. You'll want to hear about the ducks.
啊，是的，鸭子。你肯定想听听关于鸭子的事。
If I wasn't going to get rescued in the next hour or two, I had a plan to kill a bunch of ducks to get some warm blood to warm myself. So to drink some blood and to cut them open and use them to warm myself. I had this strange idea about use them as slippers.
如果我在接下来的一个小时或两个小时内没被救走，我就打算杀几只鸭子，弄点温热的血来暖身子。喝点血，把它们切开，用它们来取暖。我有个奇怪的想法，把它们当拖鞋用。
After that, I even had this psychedelic idea of floating on the ducks. Making a raft out of the ducks. Imagine a man with strings attached to the ducks, floating on the water. So it's like this duck rider.
在那之后，我甚至有了骑着鸭子的迷幻想法。用鸭子做一个木筏。想象一下一个男人系着绳子拉着鸭子，漂浮在水面上。就像个鸭子骑士。
It's totally normal for a Russian hiker to go and pick up a duck, not just to kill it, but to eat it.
对于一个俄罗斯徒步旅行者来说，去捉一只鸭子，不仅仅是杀掉它，而是为了吃掉它，这太正常了。
Like, you could just go over and pick up a duck? How did you catch the duck?
就像，你可以走过去直接抓住一只鸭子？你是怎么抓住它的？
You just go after it with a stick. I mean, you're a human being. You got more brains than a duck. You can catch it.
你只需要拿着棍子追它。我是说，你是个人类。你的大脑比鸭子好用。你能抓住它。
But I wasn't really thinking about doing it. I wasn't fantasizing about killing ducks or anything like that. I was just thinking that if it comes to that, I'll have to. I'll have to get some blood to drink. I know it sounds very violent, but I was fighting for my life.
但我并没有真的想那样做。我没有幻想杀鸭子之类的。我只是想，如果到了那一步，我就不得不那么做。我必须喝点血。我知道听起来很暴力，但我是在为生命而战。
People might laugh when they hear about being trapped on an island that's so close to civilization, and the sharks and the ducks. I knew it was a funny situation, but I really got the feeling of what is it like being on a desert island. I felt like Robinson Crusoe, you know?
当听到有人被困在离文明如此之近的岛上，还有鲨鱼和鸭子的事，人们可能会笑。我知道这很滑稽，但我真的体会到了在荒岛上的感觉。我觉得自己就像鲁滨逊·克鲁索，你知道吗？
I knew what it was like to be by yourself away from civilization with no help, and you're facing this huge problem. And the only person that's near you is you and the ghost of your death close by. So I could smell my death in the air.
我知道远离文明、没有救援、独自一人面对巨大问题是什么感觉。你身边唯一的人只有你自己和你死亡的幽灵。所以我能闻到空气中自己死亡的气息。
It turns out that the island where Alex was stranded is called Ruffle Bar. And it lies only a 20-minute boat ride away from the coast of Brooklyn. Far from being traumatized or ashamed of his exploits, Alex wanted nothing more than to go back out there.
事实证明，亚历克斯滞留的岛屿叫Ruffle Bar。它距离布鲁克林海岸只有20分钟的船程。亚历克斯远没有受到创伤或对自己所作所为感到羞愧，他唯一的愿望就是回到那里。
And from the vantage of my overpriced, undersized apartment, I wanted to see a place where you could be totally alone in the wilderness, smelling your own death in the air, while in at least theoretical commuting distance to midtown Manhattan. So we hired a boat to take us to Ruffle Bar.
从我那间价格过高、空间不足的公寓望去，我想看看那个地方——在那里你可以完全独自在荒野中，闻到死亡的气息，同时在理论上处于曼哈顿中城的通勤距离内。于是我们雇了一艘船带我们去Ruffle Bar。
In truth, I wasn't as completely surprised as some might be to learn that such a place exists. I grew up near the islands of Jamaica Bay, in a neighborhood called Canarsie. And when I was little, my friends and I would cut through the empty lots near my house to explore the mix of trash and nature on the shoreline. It was a place totally apart from the rest of my mostly urban childhood. A secret place that my friends who lived even 10 or 15 blocks away were unaware existed.
说实话，对于这样一个地方的存在，我并没有像某些人那样完全惊讶。我在牙买加湾附近的岛屿边长大，一个叫卡纳西（Canarsie）的社区。小时候，我和朋友们会穿过我家附近的空地，去探索海岸线上垃圾与自然的混合体。那是一个完全脱离了我大都市童年的地方。一个连住在10或15个街区外的朋友都不知道存在的秘密地方。
But then, the smaller islands around New York have always occupied a weird place on the edge of the city. Home to all sorts of enterprise that the citizenry either doesn't know about or prefers not to see. Sanitariums and prisons, potter's fields and grand failed schemes. Ruffle Bar itself had been the site of several of the latter. Since the Civil War, it has housed a ferry stop, a resort hotel, and even a short-lived, doomed community of some 40 buildings.
但话又说回来，纽约周围的小岛总是占据着城市边缘一个诡异的位置。它们成了各种各样公民不知道或不愿看到的企业的所在地。疗养院、监狱、无名墓地和宏大的失败计划。Ruffle Bar本身就是后者的发生地。自内战以来，它曾是渡轮停靠点、度假酒店，甚至是一个注定失败的、拥有约40栋建筑的社区所在地。
We stop in front of a concrete foundation.
我们停在一座混凝土基座前。
A what?
什么？
A building of some kind was here.
这里曾经有某种建筑。
Oh look, this is a cool thing. This is one of the World War II things that's here. You open them up, and you can go inside. There's a room in there. It might be something like a bunker or something. You see the rope here? And the rope is really old, I think. Let me take a picture of this.
噢看，这真酷。这是二战时期的东西，还留在这里。打开它，你可以进去。里面有个房间。可能是某种掩体之类的。你看到那根绳子了吗？我想那绳子很老了。让我拍张照。
There are no buildings left here. The island is returned to a deeply wild state. There's a wall of dense brush and a few trees around which sinister gulls are circling. We pass a flock of ducks who take one look of Alex and wisely move away.
这里已经没有任何建筑了。岛屿又回到了极度荒凉的状态。有一堵茂密的灌木墙和几棵树，周围盘旋着阴险的海鸥。我们经过一群鸭子，它们看了亚历克斯一眼，明智地游开了。
I'm really thinking about where the heck is the scooter. Because it seems like as we're turning, there should be more shoreline here.
我真的在想小摩托到底在哪儿。因为看起来我们转弯的地方应该有更多的海岸线。
Dude, is that it?
伙计，是那个吗？
Yep, that's exactly it. Oh, wow. This is the scooter I tried to dig out. Let me show you. Maybe you'll see the glass and stuff.
没错，就是它。噢，哇。这就是我试图挖出来的小摩托。让我给你看。也许你能看到玻璃之类的东西。
As we search for Alex's Buddhist medallion that he'd left in the excitement of the helicopter rescue, we walk across a plain of thick, dry grass, matted down like a carpet. Underneath, you can hear shells crunching and mysterious things scurrying around. Still, reminders that we are in fact in a major metropolis are always close at hand.
当我们寻找亚历克斯在直升机救援时兴奋中留下的佛教奖章时，我们走过一片厚厚的干草地，草地像地毯一样铺在地上。在下面，你可以听到贝壳的碎裂声和神秘生物穿梭的声音。不过，这里依然有我们在大都市的提醒，随时可见。
For one thing, there's the garbage-- piles of plastic and driftwood, but also shoes, steering wheels, prescription bottles, deflated balloons, a washer/dryer, several refrigerators. And, oddly, boats-- three perfectly intact ones, complete with oars. I hesitate to point these out to Alex. Though, to be fair, they're probably too heavy for him to have dragged to the water.
首先是垃圾——成堆的塑料和漂流木，还有鞋子、方向盘、处方药瓶、泄气的气球、洗衣机/烘干机、几台冰箱。奇怪的是，还有船只——三艘完好无损的，配有船桨。我犹豫要不要指给亚历克斯看。虽然平心而论，它们可能太重了，他拉不动。
And then there's this reminder of civilization.
还有这个文明的提醒。
[CELL PHONE RINGING]
[手机铃声响起]
Hold on.
等一下。
[CELL PHONE RINGING]
[手机铃声响起]
[SPEAKING RUSSIAN]
[俄语交谈]
He was always close enough to the city that simply having a cellphone would have had him tucked safely into bed within half an hour. Alex was finally rescued after seven hours, thanks to Roman and Glubochansky. Back on the boat, they were having a fine old time. A police helicopter was performing drills nearby. And apparently no slouches in the cliched castaway department themselves, they had figured out that they could signal it with a mirror-- but why rush?
他离城市一直很近，只需一部手机，半小时内就能让他安全躺在床上。亚历克斯在七小时后终于获救了，多亏了罗曼和格卢博钱斯基。回到船上，他们玩得很开心。一架警用直升机在附近进行演习。显然，他们自己在落难者的陈词滥调方面也一点不逊色，他们已经想出可以用镜子向直升机发出信号——但为什么要急呢？
We really enjoyed the time staying there. We were just sitting on the boat and smoking the last tobacco that we had left. And we make a deal that we're not going to eat each other if you're really going to get hungry. So basically we were having fun. Just a little bit, no hassle, no nothing, very quiet, nice weather.
我们真的很享受在那儿待的时间。我们只是坐在船上，抽着剩下的最后一点烟草。我们还达成协议，如果真的饿了，绝对不吃对方。所以基本上我们玩得很开心。一点点，没有麻烦，什么都没有，非常安静，天气也很好。
Oh, so you were actually holding off signaling the helicopters while you had a nice day?
噢，所以你们在过得很愉快的时候，实际上一直在推迟向直升机发出信号？
Yeah, of course. It was a nice day.
是的，当然。那天天气很好。
Still, as it began to get dark and the cigarettes ran out, the friends thought it was probably time to get a move on. A helicopter soon arrived and airlifted them off the boat. It wasn't until they were safely ashore, wrapped in blankets and being fed complimentary cookies, that either of them happened to mention that there'd been a third passenger.
不过，随着天色渐暗，烟草抽光了，朋友们觉得是时候离开了。一架直升机很快赶到，将他们从船上救起。直到他们安全上岸，裹着毯子吃着免费饼干时，他们俩才提到还有第三个乘客。
When the helicopter came back for Alex, cold, exhaustion and dehydration had left him in a trance-like, almost wild state. And for him, this island will always be a place where maybe there be monsters.
当直升机回来接亚历克斯时，寒冷、疲惫和脱水让他处于一种恍惚的、近乎野性的状态。对他来说，这个岛屿永远会是一个可能存在怪物的地方。
And when I was here, I was wondering if it's a totally wild place. Are there any animals here other than birds? I was maybe hoping to see some cool animal like a badger or something. I like badgers a lot, actually.
当我在那儿的时候，我在想它是不是一个完全荒野的地方。除了鸟类，这里还有其他动物吗？我可能希望看到一些酷动物，比如獾之类的。其实我很喜欢獾。
Is that right?
是这样吗？
Yeah, it's one of my favorite animals. You know, I like badgers for the same reason probably I like the state of Utah, where I never was. It's like something that has some kind of-- what's it called? Like a secret it's hiding? Or it's like they attract me in the way that they might be hiding something cool from me.
是的，它是我最喜欢的动物之一。你知道，我喜欢獾的原因，可能和我喜欢犹他州的原因一样，虽然我从未去过那里。它就像某种……叫什么来着？隐藏着某种秘密？或者它们吸引我的方式在于它们可能隐藏着什么酷东西不让我发现。
And that's what, after many hours spent with Alex, I find myself liking about him the most. His insistence on finding mystery and adventure everywhere he looks. It's easy to laugh at that, to write it all off as adolescent stupidity. But what if it's more than that? What if it's also a kind of adolescent magic?
这正是和亚历克斯相处许多小时后，我最喜欢他的一点。他坚持在任何地方寻找神秘和冒险。嘲笑这一点很容易，把它归结为青少年的愚蠢。但如果不仅仅如此呢？如果这是一种青春的魔力呢？
Actually, I'm thinking that this needed to happen. I think if I was a boring person, and I would just stay at home all the time and be like a nerd, I would never get into this situation. So I think this happened strictly because I was with the right people, at the right time in the right situation.
其实，我在想这件事情必须发生。我想如果我是个无聊的人，一直待在家里像个书呆子，我就永远不会陷入这种境地。所以我认为这纯粹是因为我当时和对的人在一起，在对的时间，在对的境遇下。
Think about that. Every step of the way, by almost any measure, Alex could not have been more wrong. It takes a special kind of grace to turn that into right time, right place. And how can you help but envy that?
想想看。每一步，无论从什么角度衡量，亚历克斯都不可能错得更离谱了。但将错误转化为“对的时间，对的地点”需要一种特殊的优雅。你怎么能不羡慕那种能力呢？
Who wouldn't rather live in a world where if you believe you should have an adventure, you do? In which each of your mistakes doesn't narrow your life, but expands it. In which the worst thing that could possibly happen is being bored. And you can go to sleep on stormy seas and trust that when you wake up, if you're very lucky, you'll be in Utah.
谁不想生活在这样一个世界里：如果你相信你应该去冒险，你就去；在那个世界里，你的每一次错误不会让你的生活变得狭窄，而是变得宽广；在那个世界里，可能发生的最坏的事就是感到无聊；你可以在波涛汹涌的海面上入睡，并相信当你醒来时，如果你足够幸运，你就会在犹他州。
What I'm trying to say is this-- Alex does something I never in a million years would have thought possible. He makes me think it might be cool to be a teenager again.
我想说的是——亚历克斯做了我几辈子都想不到可能做到的事情。他让我觉得再次成为一个少年可能会很酷。
There's a story that back in the 1830s, a ship carrying $54,000 in Mexican gold was hijacked by pirates outside Jamaica Bay and that the treasure was buried somewhere near Ruffle Bar. On our way back from the island I tell Alex this, and he listens with great interest.
有一个故事说，1830年代，一艘载有5.4万美元墨西哥金币的船在牙买加湾外被海盗劫持，财宝被埋在Ruffle Bar附近。回来的路上我告诉亚历克斯这个故事，他饶有兴致地听着。
If he found the treasure, he wants to know, could he keep it? Maybe, I say, if he didn't tell anybody. To which Alex answers precisely as I know he will, the only way he possibly can. He says, but what if I told everybody?
他想知道，如果他找到了宝藏，他能占有吗？我说，也许能，如果你不告诉任何人。亚历克斯回答得正如我所料，他唯一可能给出的回答。他说，但如果我告诉所有人呢？
Brett Martin, in New York.
布雷特·马丁，在纽约报道。
Coming up, the thing about Chicago that nobody outside Chicago believes about Chicago, but that actually is completely and totally true. That's in a minute, from Chicago Public Radio and Public Radio International, when our program continues.
接下来，关于芝加哥的一件事，芝加哥以外没人相信，但实际上千真万确。稍后，来自芝加哥公共广播电台和国际公共广播电台，节目继续。
It's This American Life, I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program, of course, we choose a theme, bring you a variety of different kinds of stories on that theme, Today's show, in the shadow of the city. Stories of things happening out of sight from most of us, but very close to us.
这里是《美国生活》，我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周我们都会选择一个主题，为您带来各种相关的故事。今天的主题是：在城市的阴影中。那些发生在大多数人视野之外，却离我们非常近的事情。
We've arrived at Act Two of our program. Act Two, The Thin Gray Line.
我们来到了节目的第二幕。第二幕，灰色细线。
Sometimes things in the shadow of the city should just stay in the shadow and sometimes not. Right after Hurricane Katrina, a bus tour in New Orleans started called Hurricane Katrina-- America's Greatest Catastrophe. It has since been named America's Worst Catastrophe, but same kind of idea. It is designed for out-of-towners who have come to New Orleans, so they can see for themselves, among other things, the wreckage and the devastation.
有时，城市阴影里的事情就该留在阴影里，有时则不然。卡特里娜飓风过后，新奥尔良开始了一项旅游线路，名为“卡特里娜飓风——美国最大的灾难”。后来更名为“美国最严重的灾难”，但理念一样。它专为来到新奥尔良的外地游客设计，让他们能亲自见证包括残骸和破坏在内的场景。
And we thought, you know what would be really interesting? What would be really interesting for this tour is if we could send a local. If we could ask a local to take the tour and give us their impressions.
我们觉得，你知道什么会很有趣吗？这个行程如果能派一位当地人参加会很有趣。如果我们能请一位当地人去参加这个行程，并给我们他们的感受。
Well, Cheryl Wagner's house was ruined by the levee breach. Seven feet of water on the first floor, her roof got blown off-- she seemed perfect for the job. And so one year ago, when we first heard about this, she agreed to get on the bus. And she put together this story, which we first broadcast a year ago.
嗯，谢丽尔·瓦格纳（Cheryl Wagner）的房子被大堤决口毁了。一楼积水七英尺，屋顶被掀掉——她看起来是这项任务的完美人选。一年前，当我们第一次听说这个时，她同意登上巴士。她整理了这个故事，我们在一年前首次播出。
By the time Gray Line starting running its Hurricane Katrina-- America's Greatest Catastrophe tour, I was already sick of disaster tourism. I had flipped off hippie photographers who mountain biked through the garbage of my flooded street to take close ups of my neighbor's Virgin Mary lawn grotto, ardently speckled with muck and debris. I had endured holy rollers stepping onto my porch when it was blazing hot, and I was trying to bleach what I could of my belongings, offering me a gallon of water and a mold mask, a good one, an N95, if I would sit and listen to a scripture.
当灰线旅游公司（Gray Line）开始运行“卡特里娜飓风——美国最大的灾难”行程时，我已经厌倦了灾难旅游。我曾对那些骑着山地车穿过我家被洪水淹没的街道、近距离拍摄邻居被泥浆和残骸覆盖的圣母玛利亚雕像的嬉皮士摄影师竖中指。我曾忍受那些在我家门廊上跨进跨出、在炎热天气里向我提供一加仑水和霉菌面罩（好的那种，N95）的人，只要我坐下来听经文。
And at a time when some New Orleanians were still coming home to find their mother's bodies, I watched white families thoroughly enjoy a morning outing in the ruins of a black neighborhood. I saw them lift their children onto the back bumper of a small yellow school bus that had floated into the barge that crashed through the levee. I saw these children smile and say cheese.
在一些新奥尔良人还在回家寻找母亲尸体的时候，我看着白人家庭完全享受着在黑人街区的废墟中进行的早晨游览。我看到他们把孩子抱上一辆黄色校车的后保险杠，那辆校车曾在冲破大堤的驳船中漂浮过。我看到这些孩子微笑着说“茄子”。
But even though I'm sick of disasters and their hangers-on, I'm also not immune from touring. I didn't spend Thanksgiving morning watching the Macy's Day Parade or making oyster dressing. I went over to the breach in the 17th Street Canal to see the hole that flooded my house. I was surprised to see lots of other people spending their holiday doing the same thing.
但尽管我对灾难和随行人员感到恶心，我也没有对旅游免疫。我没有花感恩节早晨去看梅西百货游行或做牡蛎馅料。我去了第17街运河的决口处，看那个淹了我家的缺口。我很惊讶地看到很多人也都在度假时做同样的事。
Even my mother, who now, oftentimes as not, cries when she comes to see me in the city, for some reason recently crossed the state line for a Saturday morning jaunt through the wreckage in Mississippi. She came back saying, you really should go see Biloxi. So I haven't made it to Biloxi yet, but with mixed feelings I decided to fork over my $35 to the professionals at Gray Line and check out the official tour of my own city.
甚至我妈妈，她现在来看我时经常会哭，最近不知为何跨过了州界，去密西西比州的残骸中转了一圈。她回来说，你真该去看看比洛克西（Biloxi）。我还没去过比洛克西，但怀着复杂的心情，我决定掏出35美元，交给灰线旅游公司的专业人士，去看看我自己城市的官方旅游线路。
Good afternoon, everyone. My name is Pat [? Dupuis. ?] I'm going to be your guide for this Katrina tour. The tour is going to mainly be based on three things, and that is the vastness of the devastation that occurred here, the importance of the city of New Orleans, and its rebirth.
下午好，各位。我的名字是帕特·杜普伊斯（Pat Dupuis）。我将是你们这次卡特里娜行程的向导。行程将主要基于三点：这里发生的破坏的广度、新奥尔良这座城市的重要性，以及它的重生。
We're on a Gray Line mini bus, pulling off from the fake lighthouse where we all met in the French Quarter. The brochure made big promises to "drive past an actual levy that breached, and see the resulting devastation." But the tour gets off to a dullish, field trip-like start.
我们在灰线旅游的小巴上，从我们在法国区见面的假灯塔出发。宣传册里做出了宏大的承诺，“驶过实际决口的大堤，观察造成的破坏。”但行程以一种枯燥的实地考察方式开始了。
On your right is an earthen levy. A levy comes from a French word meaning to raise.
在你们右手边是一个土堤。大堤（levy）一词源于法语，意为抬高。
There's maybe 20 of us on this tour-- relatives of disaster workers, some retirees, a couple from Denver in town for a wedding. Even a few unlucky folks who got bumped to our bus because their first choice, the cemetery and gris-gris tour, sold out.
我们这辆车上大约有20人——救灾人员的亲属、退休人员、一对为参加婚礼来到镇上的丹佛夫妇。还有几个倒霉蛋因为首选的“墓地和巫术游”售罄被挤到了我们这辆车上。
This is the Ernest N Morial Convention Center. This was another thing that you saw on the TV.
这里是欧内斯特·N·莫里亚尔会议中心（Ernest N Morial Convention Center）。这也是你在电视上看到过的。
In the short time it takes us to get to the convention center, some people already seem bored. A few are busy flipping through the photo album the tour guide passed of flooded houses, but that's because the outside of the cleaned-up convention center with just a few workers shining windows is boring. It would never be part of any normal city tour.
在前往会议中心的短时间内，有些人看起来已经无聊了。有几个人忙着翻看导游传阅的被洪水淹没的房屋照片集，但这只是因为擦洗干净的会议中心外围，只有几个工人擦窗户，很无聊。它永远不会成为任何普通城市旅游的一部分。
After a perfunctory drive past the now spit-shined exterior of the Superdome, we get on the interstate and head out towards Lakeview where the tourists are promised more current and less historical misery.
在匆匆驶过现在擦得闪闪发亮的超级穹顶（Superdome）外观后，我们上了州际公路，前往湖景区（Lakeview），那里承诺游客看到更多当下的、历史色彩较少的悲惨景象。
Now I want to prepare you a little bit. If you've haven't been back here, if you haven't ridden around the city, we're going to start going through some of the more devastated parts that we're allowed to go in. Like I said, we can't go into the Lower Ninth Ward, which is really bad. But you'll see enough devastation here, I think, so you'll get the whole idea of what it might have been like.
现在我想请大家有点心理准备。如果你还没回来过，如果你没在城里转过，我们将开始进入允许我们进入的一些受灾最严重的地区。如我所说，我们不能进入第九区下游，那真的很严重。但我认为你们在这里会看到足够的破坏，这样你们就能对当时的情况有个全面的了解。
You'll see some of the houses. Like this one right here-- you see it's got that red thing on it? That's tagged for demolition.
你们会看到一些房子。就像这一栋——你看到它上面有个红色的标志吗？那是标记为拆除的。
We drive past ruined houses and askew cars, and some of my fellow passengers snap photos. A few expressed surprise that anyone in New Orleans has middle class-looking homes. These were nice houses, I hear one woman say to her husband, as if this makes a family's suffering worse.
我们驶过破败的房屋和歪斜的汽车，同行的一些乘客拍了照。几个人表达了惊讶，没想到新奥尔良有人住看起来像中产阶级的家。我听到一个女人对她丈夫说，这些房子真漂亮，仿佛这让一个家庭的苦难更严重了。
No one I talked to tells me that they're particularly surprised by what they see. Maybe it's the remove of looking out the windows, or the months of pictures they've already seen on TV. All in all, despite the lurid promises made in the brochure, the Gray Line tour is a lot of driving around and wishing you could get out and take a close up look at that hole where someone hacked their way through their attic and onto their roof. But you can't, you just sit there gazing through a glass barrier, trying to absorb factoids.
没有人告诉我他们对所见到的感到特别惊讶。也许是因为隔着窗户观察的疏离感，或者是在电视上已经看了好几个月照片的原因。总而言之，尽管宣传册中做出了诱人的承诺，但灰线旅游的行程大部分时间只是开车兜风，让你恨不得下车去近距离看看那个某人通过阁楼爬上屋顶的地方。但你不能，你只能坐在那里隔着玻璃障碍注视着，试图吸收一些琐碎信息。
This is where they perfected perma press fabric, orange juice concentrate, low-fat peanut butter.
这里是他们完善常压织物、浓缩橙汁、低脂花生酱工艺的地方。
After a while I start to feel bad for our tour guide. Pat has already informed us that she and her bus driver, Sly, were out of work and tips for four months. That her house flooded, and Sly is stuck living on a cruise ship he is about to get put off of.
过了一会儿，我开始为我们的导游感到难过。帕特已经告诉我们，她和她的司机斯莱（Sly）已经有四个月没有工作和小费了。她的房子被淹了，斯莱被困在一艘即将被赶下的邮轮上。
I realize she's in a no-win situation. Gray Line has promised an all-out grisly disaster tour, but expects its tour guides to focus on rebirth as well and be a civic booster at the same time. That's why every house that's off its foundation needs to be countered with a FEMA trailer of hope nearby.
我意识到她陷入了双输的境地。灰线旅游公司承诺提供全面的灾难游，但同时要求导游专注于重生，并做一个城市推进者。这就是为什么每栋地基倾斜的房子都需要用附近希望的FEMA拖车来平衡。
But, here you have some hope. There's a FEMA trailer. There's somebody that's getting ready to work on their house. They want to move back. So it's a little ray of hope when you see these trailers.
但是，这里有一些希望。有一辆FEMA拖车。有人正准备修缮他们的房子。他们想搬回来。所以当你看到这些拖车时，那是一丝希望。
Never mind that the FEMA trailer won't have any electricity for months. This tour is not about accuracy, it's about getting to the rebirth that was promised when we first got on the mini bus. It's about presenting a grand narrative that takes all the terrible stuff that has happened and makes it OK. A bad thing happened, and then it kept happening, and then it kept happening, and then it kept happening. But now it's getting fixed, so you can go eat your beignet.
别管FEMA拖车几个月没电的事了。这个行程无关准确，而是为了实现我们第一次上小巴时承诺的重生。它是为了呈现一个宏大的叙事，把发生的所有可怕的事情都变成“没关系”。一件坏事发生了，然后它一直发生，然后它一直发生，然后它一直发生。但现在它正在被修复，所以你可以去吃你的炸面团（beignet）了。
But despite all the talk of hope, what comes through is a palpable feeling of desperation.
但尽管所有的希望言论，显现出来的是一种明显的绝望感。
You are our best ambassadors. You can go home. You can tell people that yes, you can come to New Orleans. You can breathe the air. You can drink the water. You can eat the food. You can take a tour and see the tomb of Marie Laveau.
你们是我们最好的大使。你们可以回家。你们可以告诉人们，是的，你们可以来新奥尔良。你们可以呼吸空气。你们可以喝水。你们可以吃东西。你们可以参加旅游并参观玛丽·拉沃（Marie Laveau）的墓地。
On what tour in the history of this city did any tour guide have to beg people to come to New Orleans?
在这座城市的历史上，有什么旅游行程需要向人们乞求来新奥尔良的？
You can stroll through the Garden District and see the beautiful home of Nicolas Cage and John Goodman. You can go to the plantations, plantations were high and dry.
你们可以在花园区漫步，看尼古拉斯·凯奇（Nicolas Cage）和约翰·古德曼（John Goodman）漂亮的家。你们可以去种植园，种植园里地势很高，很干燥。
I understand what Gray Line is trying to do. It's just depressing that they have to do it and that they're choosing to do it that particular way-- trying to get help by sugarcoating the problem. If you really wanted people to understand Hurricane Katrina-- America's Greatest Catastrophe, you'd have to give a completely different disaster tour.
我明白灰线旅游公司试图做什么。只是令人沮丧的是他们不得不这样做，而且他们选择用这种特定的方式来做——试图通过粉饰问题来寻求帮助。如果你真的想让人了解“卡特里娜飓风——美国最大的灾难”，你就必须提供一个完全不同的灾难旅游。
And with that in mind, as a public service I'm about to save you $35 and take you on my own tour. It won't go near the French Quarter, it won't be on a bus, and it starts here.
考虑到这一点，作为一项公共服务，我准备为你省下35美元，带你进行我自己的行程。它不会靠近法国区，不会在巴士上，而且从这里开始。
I want you to know that we talked [INAUDIBLE] about FEMA this and Federal this, and I'm sick and tired of Federal anything! I'm sick of it.
我希望你们知道，我们谈论了FEMA的这个，联邦的那个，我厌倦了任何联邦的东西！我受够了。
Our first stop, the perpetual public meeting. The one I've been attending nonstop since I got back in September. This was recorded at the public comment portion of the Bring New Orleans Back Commission's Urban Planning Committee final report presentation held at a downtown hotel a few weeks ago. But it could be from any number of official and unofficial state, local and neighborhood meetings that go on in New Orleans now almost every day of the week.
我们的第一站，永无止境的公共会议。自从九月份回来，我就没停过参加。这是在几周前一家市中心酒店举行的“重建新奥尔良委员会”城市规划委员会最终报告演示的公开评论部分录下的。但它可能是任何在新奥尔良几乎每周每天都在进行的官方或非官方州、地方和社区会议中的一个。
I am a working person. I pay Federal taxes. Because I want everybody to hear what I'm saying-- FEMA comes out of my damn paycheck.
我是一个劳动者。我缴纳联邦税。因为我希望每个人都听到我在说什么——FEMA来自我该死的工资单。
There are economic planning meetings, arts planning meetings, education planning meetings, government effectiveness meetings, city council meetings, neighborhood meetings, SBA information seminars. Since the storm, there's even a new section in the Times Picayune that lists the locations and times of that week's meetings.
有经济规划会议、艺术规划会议、教育规划会议、政府效能会议、市议会会议、社区会议、SBA信息研讨会。自从暴风雨后，《时代皮卡尤恩报》（Times Picayune）甚至开辟了一个新版块，列出了当周这些会议的地点和时间。
These meetings are overwhelming-- not only because of their frequency, but also because of their intensity. At some of the early public meetings back in October, old women would step up to the mic and cry. Old men would address the mayor as if he were a young man, saying things like, I don't believe we've had the opportunity to meet. Countless New Orleanians drive hours from other towns and other states to come to the meetings with the same message. My grandmother, my auntie, is in Texas getting sick from this stress, and I'm here today to find out what you're going to do about it.
这些会议令人窒息——不仅仅是因为频率，还因为强度。十月份早期的一些公开会议上，老妇人走上麦克风哭泣。老人们像对年轻人一样向市长说话，说着：“我不认为我们有机会见过面。”无数新奥尔良人从其他城镇和州开车几个小时来参加会议，带着同样的信息：我的祖母、我的阿姨在德克萨斯州因为压力病倒了，我今天来是为了弄清楚你们打算怎么处理它。
The people on this commission, I thank you very much for your time. If you can't give us direction, get the hell out of the way. That's all we're asking for.
在这个委员会的人们，我非常感谢你们的时间。如果你们不能给我们指导，就赶紧滚开。这就是我们要的全部。
Now that some of these meetings seem to be lurching toward a final decision phase, people listen to them on the radio, watch them on the news, read about them in the paper, or see them whole on public access. Weeks ahead of time, rumors fly about whether or not the city is going to declare your neighborhood viable or not. Whether or not you'll be allowed to fix your house. And if you do fix your house, whether the government will try to acquire it by eminent domain anyway and wipe your neighborhood from the face of the Earth.
现在这些会议似乎正蹒跚走向最终决定阶段，人们在收音机里听，在新闻里看，在报纸上读，或者在公共电视上完整地看。几周前，关于城市是否会将你的社区宣布为“可行”的传言四起。无论你是否被允许修房子。如果你修了房子，政府是否还会通过征用权（eminent domain）试图获得它，将你的社区从地球表面抹去。
After certain meetings, people go around saying things like that Joe Canizaro wants to put a big green dot on my house. Over my dead body.
在某些会议后，人们会到处说类似“乔·卡尼扎罗（Joe Canizaro）想在我的房子上画一个大绿点”之类的话。除非我死。
This perpetual public meeting spills out into everyday life. In line at the grocery store, strangers tell me the exact dollar figure they owe on their ruined homes. Grown men wander into my backyard and tell me how much they miss their pet parrot they had to let go the night before the storm. Once a week, a stranger starts crying in front of me.
这种永无止境的公共会议蔓延到了日常生活中。在杂货店排队时，陌生人告诉我他们因被毁房屋而欠下的确切金额。成年男人走进我的后院，告诉我他们有多么想念在暴风雨前不得不放走的宠物鹦鹉。每周，都会有一个陌生人在我面前哭泣。
Sometimes the perpetual public meeting turns surreal. The other day I was taking a walk along Bayou St. John and the police scuba divers were out there dragging the water for another suspected suicide. A man stopped his car, got out and walked over to me. His first question was quick, what are they looking for? But his second question, the real reason he stopped, was pure public meeting.
有时永无止境的公共会议变得离奇。那天我正沿着圣约翰河口（Bayou St. John）散步，警察潜水员正在那儿打捞另一名疑似自杀者的尸体。一个人把车停下，下车走到我身边。他的第一个问题很快，“他们在找什么？”但他的第二个问题，他停下来的真正原因，是纯粹的“公共会议”。
Did you get any water? Meaning, was I flooded? Good, him, too. Then you've been down to City Hall to deal with that permitting? Can you believe that crap? I live in the East, those guys were talking about making a park out of my house. I'm been staying out in River Ridge now, but we're getting it together.
你家进水了吗？意思是，我是不是被淹了？很好，他也是。那你去市政厅办许可了吗？你能相信那破事吗？我住在东部，那些人谈论要把我的房子改成公园。我现在住在河岭（River Ridge），但我们正在搞定它。
Next stop, City Park, near the police department horse stables. One of the many places that has been transformed by the levy break. Not just ruined, but fundamentally altered.
行程下一站，城市公园（City Park），警察局马厩附近。这是被大堤决口改变的众多地方之一。不仅仅是毁坏，而是发生了根本性的改变。
Lots of different people used to use this area. Near the back, hikers, bird watchers, dog walkers and gay cruisers used to share a shady wooded trail. Nearby, a soccer field sometimes filled with the battle cries of military reenactors. My boyfriend and I went to City Park one day recently and stumbled into a Hooverville, complete with guys who look like carnies rubbing their hands over trash can fires. Streets next to the soccer field are now clogged with flood scum encrusted cars and limousines that someone towed there to strip before bringing them to the crusher.
过去有很多不同的人使用这个区域。在后部，远足者、观鸟者、遛狗者和寻找同性的恋人曾经分享一条阴凉的林间小道。附近，一个足球场有时填满了军事重演者的战斗呐喊。我和男友最近一天去了城市公园，偶然闯入一个胡佛村（Hooverville），里面有看起来像马戏团杂工的人在垃圾桶火堆上搓着手。足球场旁边的街道现在堵满了被洪水覆盖的汽车和豪华轿车，有人把它们拖到那儿，在送到粉碎机前把它们拆光。
Nearby, there are sad sack teepees fashioned of blue roofs tarps. Teepees with people living in them. Some asking around turned up that these were a bunch of Apache Indians who'd been promised work and then abandoned by their contractor.
附近，有悲伤的帐篷，是用蓝色屋顶篷布制成的。帐篷里住着人。询问得知，这是一群阿帕奇印第安人，他们曾被承诺有工作，结果被承包商抛弃了。
The back of City Park has turned to a place of chaos and filth that doesn't give you the Saturday barbecue feeling it did before the flood. It gives me the feeling I got right after the storm. After we first got back to the city and we saw an old man riding a bicycle, pulling a laughing old woman on a hospital gurney behind him. There were not many people around. The old gurney couple did not seem like a good sign.
城市公园的后部变成了一个混乱和污秽的地方，再也给不了你洪水前那种周六烧烤的感觉。它给我的感觉和暴风雨后的一样。当我们第一次回到城里，看到一个老人骑着自行车，后面拉着一个在医院平车上大笑的老太太。周围没有多少人。平车上的老两口看起来不像个好兆头。
Next stop on my tour, my house. Outside, the picket fence is gone, and there's a water line. Inside, it's gutted to the frame and studs.
下一站，我的房子。在外面，纠察围栏没了，还有一道水痕。在里面，它被掏空到了框架和龙骨。
Since I've had to sleep upstairs in a room with the walls cut open and siding blown off, when I open my eyes in the morning, like the Apache Indians, I see blue tarp. I brush my teeth at a spigot in the backyard with a Dixie cup. Friends come to see me and accidentally drive past our house, say the place unrecognizable now.
因为我不得不住在楼上的一个房间里，墙壁被切开，护墙板被吹走，所以我早上睁开眼时，就像那些阿帕奇印第安人一样，看到的是蓝色篷布。我用迪克西杯（Dixie cup）在后院的水龙头刷牙。朋友来看我，不小心开车路过了我们的房子，说现在完全认不出来了。
My boyfriend Jake and I are getting a little unrecognizable, too. There are ways in which we have grown strange to ourselves. Gone a little south, like City Park and the gurney couple.
我和男友杰克也变得有点认不出来。我们在某些方面对自己变得陌生了。像城市公园和平车上的老两口一样，向南（南方即衰落/死亡）走了一点。
One afternoon, after a long day a prying lath off walls and carting wheelbarrows of plaster and rubble to the curb, I heard laughter and breaking glass from what used to be my backyard garden. Jake and his friend, the carpenter, were swinging their legs off the back balcony. They had found a BB gun and were shooting out the few windows that were left on our shed.
一天下午，在 Pry 了一天墙上的板条，把成捆的石膏和碎石运到路边后，我听到后院花园传来笑声和玻璃破碎声。杰克和他的木匠朋友正把腿荡在后阳台上。他们找到了一把BB枪，正在把棚子上剩下的几扇窗户射碎。
Check this out, they said, and shattered another window. Don't do that, the old me, the pre-gurney me said. Why not? I looked around, the tin roof of our shed was peeled up. The gardenia, angel trumpet and sweet olive that I had planted almost a decade ago were all dead.
“看看这个，”他们说，又打碎了一扇窗户。“别那样做，”原来的我，那个“平车前”的我说道。“为什么不？”我环顾四周，棚子的锡屋顶被掀开了。我近十年前种下的栀子花、天使号角和甜橄榄都死了。
The fence was down. And behind us, the neighbor's wall had fallen off of his second story leaving their upstairs kitchen exposed like a dollhouse. With the kitchen clock still on the wall, open to the sky.
篱笆倒了。在我们身后，邻居的墙从二楼掉落，楼上的厨房像娃娃屋一样暴露出来。厨房的时钟还挂在墙上，向天空敞开。
At night now, we can see downtown hotels shimmering across the dark and flooded blocks, like Emerald City in the distance. Why not shoot our shed windows out? OK, said the post-gurney me, but don't miss and hit the neighbor's China cabinet. They might want those plates.
现在到了晚上，我们可以看到市中心的酒店在黑暗和洪水泛滥的街区闪烁，像远处的翡翠城。为什么不把我们棚子的窗户打碎？“好吧，”那个“平车后”的我说道，“但别射偏，打到邻居的瓷器柜。他们可能还要那些盘子。”
You have reached the Federal Emergency Management Agency.
你已经连接到联邦紧急事务管理局（FEMA）。
Next stop, 1-800-621-FEMA. Welcome to the utterly exhausting soul crushing grind that is having to juggle city, state, government and insurance bureaucracies for five months straight with no likely end in sight.
下一站，1-800-621-FEMA。欢迎来到极其耗尽精力、粉碎灵魂的磨难，即不得不连续五个月在城市、州、政府和保险官僚机构之间斡旋，而且看不到尽头。
Our first FEMA battle was over our roof. It blew off, and so we needed a tarp. FEMA wouldn't tarp it, so we climbed up a few stories and tarped it ourselves. A month or so later, FEMA sent someone over who untarped our tarping, but only retarped half of it. So we had to call and fight and explain and call, then give up and reclimb and retarp a, by then, even slicker roof.
我们第一次和FEMA的战斗是为了屋顶。它被吹走了，所以我们需要一张篷布。FEMA不会帮我们盖，所以我们爬了几层楼自己盖了。一个月左右后，FEMA派人过来，拆了我们盖的篷布，但只重盖了一半。所以我们不得不打电话，抗争，解释，再打电话，最后放弃，重新爬上去，重新盖上一张在那时已经更滑的屋顶。
Everyone has stories like this. People accidentally bumped from FEMA's trailer list. People with keys and no trailer. People with trailers and no keys. Trailers blocking doors of houses people are trying to renovate.
每个人都有这样的故事。人们不小心被从FEMA的拖车名单中删掉。有钥匙没拖车的人。有拖车没钥匙的人。拖车挡住了人们正试图装修的房子的门口。
Meanwhile, teams of contractors come and go. Recently, an article in the paper confirmed what everyone suspected-- that the government pays at minimum almost $60,000 a trailer. The same amount it would likely cost to rewire and re-sheetrock many someones' house.
同时，承包商团队来来去去。最近，报纸上的一篇文章证实了大家的怀疑——政府支付每辆拖车至少近6万美元。这笔钱足够翻新和重修许多人的房子了。
Add to this phone books that no longer work, since half the people and businesses in them are now gone. The constant stream of misinformation, correction and re-misinformation. And the garbage piles which get shuffled back and forth as dozens of crews argue about whose job it is to pick up shingles, and whose job it is to pick up the fridges, and whose job it is to pick up that dead dog still in the pink toy box.
再加上不再好用的电话簿，因为里面半数的人和企业都没了。不断涌入的错误信息、修正和再错误信息。还有那些被来回推搡的垃圾堆，因为几十个工队在争论谁负责清理屋顶瓦片，谁负责清理冰箱，谁负责清理那个还在粉红色玩具箱里的死狗。
But like Pat at Gray Line, I feel compelled to throw in that FEMA trailer of hope, because there is some hope. I catch glimpses of it in the new-found engineering wonkiness among Louisianans who now speak of sheet piling ratios and Dutch hydraulic engineering over coffee. And the blond Southern women strapping on work gloves over their manicures and donning orange vests to pick up garbage in neighborhoods that they never set their SUVs in before. And then the folks who drive by and honk and cheer these ladies of garbage on, who sometimes pull over, get out and help.
但像灰线旅游公司的帕特一样，我忍不住要加入那辆“希望的FEMA拖车”，因为确实还有些希望。我在路易斯安那人新发现的工程痴迷中看到了希望，他们现在谈论板桩比例和荷兰水利工程。还有穿着橙色背心、戴着工作手套在从未开SUV进过的街区清理垃圾的南方金发女性。还有那些开车经过、鸣笛并为这些垃圾女工加油的民众，他们有时会靠边停车，下来帮忙。
It's in the growing number of "apolitical" rallies. A strange new Southern phenomenon where moms strap their schoolgirl daughters into life vests whenever Bush comes to town to run his mouth. The trailer of hope is also where you least expect to find it-- right on my own wrecked street, in the gutted house on the corner where a man lives upstairs with a lantern.
希望在于越来越多的“非政治性”集会。一种奇怪的南方新现象，每当布什来访时，妈妈们都会把她们女儿穿上救生衣，听他胡说八道。希望的拖车也在你最意想不到的地方——就在我那条破败街道上，角落里那栋掏空的房子里，一个男人用灯笼住在楼上。
And the moment the other night when Jake and I walked our dogs by and he invited us to lay our hands on the side of his home. He said that two roofers had just fallen 40 feet off the top of it, bounced on the flood-wrecked grass and survived. That we should touch his ruined house because it was blessed.
还有那天晚上，我和杰克遛狗经过，他邀请我们把手放在他家的墙上。他说两名屋顶工刚才从上面掉了40英尺高，摔在被洪水摧毁的草地上，竟然活了下来。他让我们触摸他破败的房子，因为这里被祝福过。
And last month, while Americans flew into one of the most ludicrous nationwide fits of reverse-racism hysteria I've witnessed in my lifetime over our mayor's hapless deployment of a parliament lyric, over Chocolate City, people who live here were working things out. A conversation I overheard between a Middle Eastern store clerk and his black customer about some shootings at a second line parade made me glad to be, however imperfectly, home.
还有上个月，当美国人陷入了我一生中见过的最荒谬的全国性反向种族主义歇斯底里，关于我们市长对巧克力之城（Chocolate City）歌词的笨拙部署时，住在这里的人们正在解决问题。我听到的一段对话，一名中东商店职员和他的一位黑人顾客谈论游行中的枪击事件，让我感到回家是值得的，尽管并不完美。
That cutting up at the second line Sunday, the customer said, get that out of here. That's nothing but foolishness. Yes, the store clerk nodded, it is foolish. It is not very chocolate.
“星期天游行时的捣乱，”顾客说，“把它赶走。那只不过是愚蠢行为。”“是的，”店员点了点头，“那是愚蠢的。那不怎么‘巧克力’。”
Cheryl Wagner, she lives in mid-city in New Orleans. She did that story for us a year ago. She says these days her house does have walls. And the main difference with New Orleans now, she says, is that it's so violent. She says she still believes in a trailer called hope, except now she says she's scared she might get shot in it.
谢丽尔·瓦格纳，她住在新奥尔良市中心。她一年前为我们做了那个故事。她说现在她的房子确实有了墙。她说新奥尔良现在的最大区别是太暴力了。她说她依然相信有一辆叫“希望”的拖车，只是现在她说她害怕在拖车里会被枪击。
[MUSIC - "CHOCOLATE CITY," ROGER TROUTMAN]
[音乐 - "巧克力之城"，罗杰·特劳特曼]
Act Three, Yes, in My Backyard. Now this story about some of the mysterious things happening on the edges of the city, in the shadow of city, right under our noses. And to put this story in some context, we're going to turn now to Jorge Just.
第三幕，是的，在我家后院。现在这个关于在城市边缘、城市阴影中、就在我们眼皮底下发生的神秘事情的故事。为了让这个故事有一定的背景，我们现在转向豪尔赫·贾斯特（Jorge Just）。
You may remember Jorge. He's done some stories for our program. He says that when you move to a new city, you cannot get into the regular conversations that everybody else gets into. He found this out a little while back when he did the one thing that everyone in Chicago agrees is the very worst thing that anybody can do. He moved to New York.
你们可能记得豪尔赫。他为我们的节目做过一些故事。他说，当你搬到一个新城市时，你无法进入别人都在谈论的常规对话中。不久前，当他做了芝加哥每个人都认为是最糟糕的一件事时，他发现了这一点。他搬到了纽约。
All New Yorkers want to talk about is what subway train to take to get from point A to point B. And it goes on and on, and you can't say anything. You can't be like, you know they discovered a 10th planet? And they'll be like, well, you would take the DMZ.
纽约人想谈的全部就是从A点到B点该坐哪趟地铁。这没完没了，你什么话都插不上。你不能说：“你知道吗，他们发现了一颗第十颗行星？”他们会说：“嗯，那你应该坐DMZ线。”
Take it to the 10th planet.
带它去那颗第十行星。
It's inescapable. And when that conversation finally peters out, it somehow-- and it doesn't fail-- turns into a conversation about cell phone reception. You can't get into the conversation. You don't know where the dead spots are. So you can't do any small talk.
这是无法逃避的。当那段对话最终平息时，它不知何故——它从不失误——变成了关于手机信号的谈话。你无法加入谈话。你不知道哪里是盲点。所以你没法聊些轻松的话题。
So what happens is the small talk becomes, oh, you just moved to New York? Where are you from? Oh, you're from Chicago? How do you like New York? How do you like New York? Everybody wants to know how you like New York, because they want you to say, New York's the greatest place that I've ever been to. And I've burned all of my connections to anywhere that I've ever been before because I love it so much here.
所以发生的情况是，闲聊变成了，“哦，你刚搬到纽约？你从哪儿来？哦，你是芝加哥人？你喜欢纽约吗？你喜欢纽约吗？”每个人都想知道你喜不喜欢纽约，因为他们想让你说：“纽约是我去过最伟大的地方。我已经烧毁了和我去过的任何地方的所有联系，因为我太爱这里了。”
When in fact, people would say so how do you like New York? You're like, well, you know, I like it. It's big and stuff, but I really like Chicago. Oh really? What's Chicago like? Chicago's this wonderful dreamland where there's a bar on every corner and the bridges smell like chocolate.
而事实上，当人们问“你觉得纽约怎么样？”时，你会说：“嗯，你知道，我喜欢。它很大之类的，但我真的很喜欢芝加哥。”“哦真的吗？芝加哥是什么样的？”“芝加哥是一个美妙的梦幻之地，每个街角都有酒吧，桥上闻起来像巧克力。”
And then you pretty much have a silence, and the ice in your glass would clink a couple of times. And then they'd say the bridges smell like chocolate? And then I'd describe how wonderful it is that the bridges smelled like chocolate.
然后你就会陷入沉默，杯子里的冰块会叮当响几声。然后他们会说“桥上闻起来像巧克力？”然后我会描述桥上闻起来像巧克力是多么美妙。
And this is something that people in New York have never ever, ever, ever, ever, ever believed. But, if you get up early in the morning, and it's sort of quiet out, and you go to the right bridge. And it's just that sort of magic twinkling hour where the sun's coming up, and you're in a big city but nobody's around. Every now and again they smell like brownies.
这是纽约人从来、从来、从来、从来、从来、从来没相信过的事情。但是，如果你清晨早起，外面比较安静，你走到对的桥上。那只是那种魔力闪烁的时刻，太阳升起，你在大城市，但周围没人。每隔一段时间，它们闻起来就像布朗尼。
Yeah, that's actually true. And the reason why is because there's a chocolate plant on the West side that spews the smell of chocolate.
是的，那确实是真的。原因是因为西侧有一家巧克力厂，它喷发出巧克力的气味。
Yeah, the smell of magic. To say the bridge smells like chocolate doesn't convey what actually happens. What actually happens is that when you're walking across a bridge and you're dodging cars. And it's a bridge over a dead river in the middle of a part of town that is industrial and totally unnatural.
是的，魔力的气味。说桥上闻起来像巧克力并不能传达真正发生的事情。真正发生的事情是，当你走过一座桥，你在躲避车辆。那是一座横跨死水的桥，位于城市中心一个工业化且完全不自然的部分。
You just sort of walk into this cloud of the sweetest memory you have of cookies being made as a child. Your sweetest childhood memory. You can walk into that, and you can walk into it by surprise, in the middle of the day, in the middle of the city.
你只是走进了一片你童年做饼干的最甜美的记忆云雾中。你最甜美的童年记忆。你可以走进它，你可以突然走进它，在白天，在城市中心。
Now you know that all this is ending, right?
现在你知道这一切都要结束了，对吧？
I know. It's like 1,000 little stabs in the heart.
我知道。这就像心口挨了一千刀。
Thanks to the federal government.
多亏了联邦政府。
It's like a million little stabs in the heart.
这就像心口挨了一百万刀。
What happened is this-- somebody complained about the chocolate smell. They complained to the Environmental Protection Agency. And the federal government, ever responsive to even a single complaint from any of its citizens anywhere in the country, leapt into action. They sent inspectors to the Blommer Chocolate Company, which has been making chocolate bars and other goodies on Chicago's West Side since 1939.
事情是这样的——有人投诉了巧克力味。他们向环境保护署（EPA）投诉。联邦政府，对全国任何地方任何公民的一项投诉都能迅速响应，采取了行动。他们派检查员去布洛默巧克力公司（Blommer Chocolate Company），该公司自1939年以来一直在芝加哥西区生产巧克力棒和其他糖果。
Inspectors found that too much cocoa dust was going into the air, more than is legal under federal standards. The plant installed filtering equipment. In fact, they say they've been planning to get that equipment in place even before the EPA dropped by. In any case, fewer cocoa particles in the air means less delicious chocolatey aroma.
检查员发现太多的可可粉进入空气，超过了联邦标准规定的合法范围。工厂安装了过滤设备。事实上，他们说在EPA上门之前就已经计划安装这些设备了。无论如何，空气中可可颗粒变少意味着美味的巧克力芳香变少了。
It's kind of curious to think of one small chocolate factory. Somebody complained and they went out there and looked. And yes, there's a problem, and we're going to fix it. But yet you have thousands of times where it's happened at the power plants, and nothing's happened.
想到一家小巧克力工厂真让人好奇。有人投诉，他们就去了那里看。是的，有问题，我们要解决它。但你成千上万次在发电厂发生同样的情况，却什么都没发生。
That's Brian Urbaszewski, Director of Environmental Health Programs for the American Lung Association in Chicago. And as he points out-- it has been widely reported here-- the Illinois Attorney General's office has documented over 7,600 violations, similar to the chocolate company violation, at six coal plants in Illinois in the last six years. And the EPA has never gone after any of those coal plants.
那是布莱恩·厄巴谢夫斯基（Brian Urbaszewski），芝加哥美国肺脏协会环境健康项目主任。正如他指出的那样——这里有广泛报道——伊利诺伊州总检察长办公室在过去六年中记录了伊利诺伊州六家燃煤电厂超过7,600次违反规定，类似于巧克力公司的违规行为。而EPA从未对那些煤电厂采取过行动。
OK, let's step back a minute. Because chocolate factories are not a major source of this fine particle pollution. When you look at power plants, they're responsible for about a quarter of the problem.
好吧，让我们退后一步。因为巧克力工厂不是这种细颗粒物污染的主要来源。当你观察发电厂时，它们造成了大约四分之一的问题。
And chocolate-- is chocolate a quarter of the problem as well?
那么巧克力呢——巧克力也是四分之一的问题吗？
No. It's probably far, far, far less than 1%.
不。它可能远远、远远、远远小于1%。
Oh. Now, there's a quote that you gave, where you used an animal metaphor that I've seen quoted widely in a million articles that I just would like you to repeat here for our listeners.
噢。现在，你给过一个引语，你用了一个动物隐喻，我在一百万篇文章中看到过被广泛引用，我只想请你在我们的听众面前重复一下。
Oh, I don't know if I can. Actually, if this is the wolves--
噢，我不知道我能不能。实际上，如果这是关于狼群的——
Mmm-hmm.
嗯哼。
--and the ant thing?
——和蚂蚁那件事？
I'm afraid so.
恐怕是的。
I've actually got San Francisco animal activists after me for that thing, saying that wolves are not dangerous to humans.
为了那件事，我实际上招惹了旧金山的动物权利活动家，他们说狼对人类并不危险。
That being said-- well, I'll say it if you don't feel like you can. You said that what the EPA was doing with this chocolate factory and ignoring the coal plants, you said, "it's like crushing an ant when there's a pack of wolves around, then claiming you have saved people from harm."
话虽如此——好吧，如果你不想说，我说。你说EPA对那家巧克力工厂采取的行动，而忽视了煤电厂，你说：“这就像在有狼群出没时踩死一只蚂蚁，然后声称你已经把人们从伤害中拯救出来。”
How about if we say it's like crushing an ant--
如果我们说这就像踩死一只蚂蚁——
Don't be scared of those animal rights people.
别怕那些动物权利人士。
No, I'm just trying to think-- I'll use sharks instead. Nobody likes sharks.
不，我只是在想——我会用鲨鱼代替。没人喜欢鲨鱼。
I just feel like my entire relationship to government right now can be summed up by this story. There's all these things that are throwing particles in the air, and the only one I like is the one they're getting rid of.
我只是觉得我现在和政府的全部关系都可以归结为这个故事。空气中到处都是排放颗粒的东西，但我唯一喜欢的那个，他们却正在消灭它。
Yeah, and that's my frustration as well.
是的，这也是我的挫败感。
The federal EPA hasn't been talking to the press about the chocolate factory. When I called the Illinois State EPA, the manager of compliance and enforcement for the Bureau of Air, a cheerful public servant named Julie Armitage, informed me that there has been a misunderstanding. Yes, she said, the coal plants had belched out too many particles 7,600 times. But you see, these times was very, very short. At the least, a momentary spike, at the most, six minutes long.
联邦EPA没有就巧克力工厂接受媒体采访。当我给伊利诺伊州EPA打电话时，负责空气局合规与执法的一位经理，一位名叫朱莉·阿米蒂奇（Julie Armitage）的开朗公务员告诉我，这是一个误解。是的，她说，煤电厂喷射了太多颗粒7,600次。但你知道，这些时间非常、非常短。最轻微的是瞬间尖峰，最长的是六分钟。
Each one was a blip, she said. Automatic monitoring equipment is going 24-hours a day taking readings. Add up all the blips per year, and you get 211 blips, per plant, per year. Meaning that well over 99% of the time, the plants are in compliance with the law.
每一次都是一个“闪烁”（blip），她说。自动监测设备24小时运行，进行读数。每年把所有的闪烁加起来，每个工厂每年会有211次闪烁。这意味着99%以上的时间，工厂是符合法律规定的。
Yes, taken out of context, it appears to be a very bad situation. Put into context, it's virtually a non-issue.
是的，脱离语境看，这似乎是一个非常糟糕的情况。放在语境中，这几乎不是问题。
And as to the fact that there's still chocolate smell in Chicago, but now it is less chocolate smell.
至于芝加哥还有巧克力味，但现在是较少的巧克力味。
You know, I'm not really in a position. Would I prefer to not have had the hullabaloo that broke loose? Yes.
你知道，我真的无法发表意见。我是否宁愿没发生那场骚乱？是的。
And you don't feel any sort of twinge as an environmental regulator who's here to make our world a better place, as you are, that that could be the upshot of the whole thing?
作为一名环境监管者，你在这里是为了让我们的世界变得更美好，你难道没有一点点刺痛感吗，那就是整个事情的结果？
That the chocolate aroma disappears?
巧克力芳香消失了？
Yeah. You don't feel any sort of twinge if that were to happen?
是的。如果发生了这种事，你难道没有一点刺痛感吗？
Well, unfortunately, my job here is to ensure compliance with environmental laws and regulations, and--
嗯，不幸的是，我在这里的工作是确保遵守环境法律和法规，而且——
Wherever this sentence is going, this is exactly not the answer we see the people of Illinois want to hear. We don't want to hear about laws and regulations.
无论这句话要说什么，这绝对不是伊利诺伊州人民想听到的答案。我们不想听法律和法规。
Well, but you know, they're there for a reason. And for the most part--
嗯，但你知道，它们存在是有原因的。而且在大多数情况下——
Everybody was following the rules, she says. The feds inspected, just like they're supposed to. Blommers was, in fact, emitting too much chocolate, end of story.
每个人都在遵守规则，她说。联邦政府检查了，就像他们应该做的那样。布洛默确实排放了太多的巧克力，故事结束。
She said the fact that the coal plants emit more pollution than Blommers, well, it's like when you're driving 68 in a 65 zone, and the cop pulls you over. You broke the law. It doesn't matter that other people might be doing 70, or 80, or 90, or dare I say 7,600.
她说，煤电厂排放的污染比布洛默多这一事实，嗯，就像你在限速65的区域开到68，警察把你拦下来。你违反了法律。别人可能开了70、80、90，或者我敢说7,600，这并不重要。
Well, the program was produced today by Diane Cook and myself, with Alex Blumberg, Jane Feltes, Sarah Koenig, Amy O'Leary and Lisa Pollak. Our senior producer's Julie Snyder. Elizabeth Meister runs our website.
嗯，今天的节目由黛安·库克（Diane Cook）和我自己制作，亚历克斯·布隆伯格（Alex Blumberg）、简·费尔特斯（Jane Feltes）、萨拉·科尼格（Sarah Koenig）、艾米·奥利里（Amy O'Leary）和丽莎·波拉克（Lisa Pollak）参与。我们的资深制作人是朱莉·斯奈德（Julie Snyder）。伊丽莎白·迈斯特（Elizabeth Meister）负责我们的网站。
Production help from Sam Hallgren, Thea Chaloner, Seth Lind and Tommy Andreas. Music help from Jessica Hopper.
制作协助来自山姆·霍尔格伦（Sam Hallgren）、西娅·查洛纳（Thea Chaloner）、塞思·林德（Seth Lind）和汤米·安德烈亚斯（Tommy Andreas）。音乐协助来自杰西卡·霍珀（Jessica Hopper）。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
[鸣谢]
Our website where you where can get our free, absolutely free podcast, or listen to our old shows by audio streaming, www.thisamericanlife.org. Also there this week, details about our live tour. Tickets available in some cities, but they're going fast. We're there this week.
我们的网站，在那里你可以获取我们的免费，绝对免费的播客，或者通过音频流收听我们的旧节目，www.thisamericanlife.org。那里还有本周关于我们巡演的详情。部分城市门票在售，但售罄很快。我们本周在那里。
This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International. This American Life is brought to you by Volkswagen, safe happens.
《美国生活》由国际公共广播电台发行。《美国生活》由大众汽车带给您，安全至上（Safe happens）。
WBEZ management oversight for our program provided by Torey Malatia, who asked me to tell you that he can kick the ass of anybody in Manhattan, Brooklyn, Queens, the Bronx.
我们节目的WBEZ管理监督由托里·马拉蒂亚（Torey Malatia）提供，他让我告诉你，他可以踢曼哈顿、布鲁克林、皇后区、布朗克斯任何人的屁股。
And this is something that people in New York have never ever, ever, ever, ever, ever believed.
这是纽约人从来、从来、从来、从来、从来、从来没相信过的事情。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带回更多《美国生活》的故事。
PRI, Public Radio International.
PRI，国际公共广播电台。